bueno saberlo está bien acabo de dejar
ir a la mitad de ustedes así que jubile
uno contra treinta seleccionar entre 30
chicos le pedimos al orden escoger entre
30 coincidencias potenciales en persona
selecciona a la derecha me gusta y a la
izquierda no me gusta
cuéntanos de tu experiencia en las
aplicaciones de citas a una serie de
primeras citas y por citas digo ir por
una cerveza luego empezamos a conversar
un poco y dejamos de hablar poco a poco
y luego él es el primero en verme en
instagram y eso es todo y nunca volvemos
a hablar de nuevo es raro pasar del
mundo de citas en aplicaciones a estar
en persona
los estoy escuchando estamos listos para
empezar agitar chicos busquen a los
chicos solos dios está bien
y dijo dios mío
tienes ojos hermosos gracias
si ellos están listos
muy bien
comencemos
lo siento lo siento mucho
es
hola
bien
eso fue tan incómodo 8 coincidencias
potenciales si estuvieran en una
aplicación de citas y hubiesen
seleccionado no pueden retirarse ahora
bueno saberlo
no estoy herida estoy bien acabo de
dejar ir a la mitad de ustedes así que
seis coincidencias la orden tiene
treinta minutos para conocer rápidamente
a los seis chicos
con gusto conocerte hola me llamo lauren
empiezo de una vez mi nombre escala
mucho gusto soy javier a qué te dedicas
o qué hace el ejército o estupendo tú no
eres de por aquí por casualidad o soy yo
doy doy esa impresión no es sólo que
siento un pequeño acento solo soy de
ohio y que hay para ser enojada no
tenemos el salón de la fama del rock y
también sabes que suena muy aburrido
lo siento debería decirlo con entusiasmo
está el salón de la fama fuiste muy
graciosa cuando estuvimos un rato en ese
semicírculo y mi sentido del humor es mi
mecanismo de defensa quieres que tus
hijos entren a un equipo si mis hijos te
dan atletas son de las empacadoras
y jugamos juntos me encanta the office
si cuenta cómo pasan tiempo a la iglesia
así es
estoy buscando una iglesia iba a visitar
varios vuelos drones hago carreras y
estilo libre
ayer tuve una carrera en una compañía
yo tengo un hijo de seis meses me
engañaron por la red
pero por otra persona diferente o solo
no se veía igual ellos no se parecía en
nada
y no sé qué tipo de aplicaciones
utilizan estas son filtros así me gustan
mucho las películas
bien importante las tres mejores
películas para ti
poder que mató el día de la
independencia y el rey león virgen las
tres son totalmente está bien te
entiendo están muy relacionadas en serio
el rey león
te gustó en conoce al conocer te gustan
conocer de gusto en conocer conocer te
gusto en conocerte gusto conocerte fue
un gusto conocerlo suerte o özil o
demasiado alto a ese extraño que sin
importar con quién estaba hablando
siempre había algo en común eso estuvo
genial hay alguien con quien te gustaría
continuar conversando
[Música]
decisión final creo que no
eso está mal no para nada bueno yo creo
que me agradaron todos como personas y
los escogí porque por una parte si me
parecieron atractivos pero no sentí
ninguna conexión con ninguno como yo
esperaba que fuera creo que me hace
falta salir más creo que soy más del
tipo de persona que dice que siempre
está ocupada y espera a que se den las
cosas ahora le daré menos prioridad a
las aplicaciones y trataré de
interactuar más con las personas así que
voy a dejar las aplicaciones por un
tiempo en persona fue difícil
muchas gracias gracias a ti genial
hola
hola hola
jubilee